pardon mon frère tu aurais pas l'heure
s'il te plaît si
pardon madame
vous auriez l'heure s'il vous plaît
11h45 oh là là là là là
je t'avais pas vu ça va
les gens sont incroyables mon vieux les
gens là à l'instant là devant moi il y a
un espèce de type tu sais grand costaud
il croise une brave ménagère avec ses
deux paniers comme ça et puis il lui
fait
vous n'auriez pas l'heure s'il vous
plaît c'est ouint sans se découvrir sans
même se découvrir attends c'est pas fini
alors il lui fait vous auriez pas
l'heure s'il vous plaît la pauvre femme
possède de paniers à terre il y en a un
des deux qui se renverse à moitié et bah
le type ne se baisse même pas pour
l'aider regarde non sur la tête de ma
fille
la pauvre femme lui fait 11h45 monsieur
à ce moment-là le type passe à côté
d'elle paf on la bousculant comme ça et
il s'en va sans même lui dire merci
alors
elle a rien dit
vers son chez soi tu sais mais branler
chapeau
[Musique]
une petite vieille reviens de faire son
marché pour toute sa famille toutes ces
économies ont été consacrées elle marche
lentement
voyez ce que je veux dire vous pensez
le mur
si même pas non vous avez l'heure c'est
tout
ces deux paniers par terre l'un de se
renverse non l'autre 11h45 dit-elle en
levant la terre le type lui avait pris
tout ce qu'il y avait dans son panier
non
Monsieur Georges
Georges
la petite vieille
de tout son long sur le trottoir je peux
pas vous le faire là parce que j'ai une
belle veste on se démettrant une corde
qui se lève péniblement
de larmes coulent de ses yeux bleu
elles repart nourrir sa maisonnée avec
ce qui reste dans son panier
en serrant les dents
sans génie
le
c'est tout
à bientôt madame la
oh mais c'est la petite Françoise tout
s'en va tout fout le camp
une brève femme 60 70 ans
comme ça elle pas sec comme ça là moi
50 kg de pommes de terre dans des cabas
parfois l'une d'elle tombée elle ne l'a
ramassait même pas pourquoi mais tant
c'est fort c'est têtusé par les hommes
Marc il lui restait tu sais dans les
yeux cette petite lueur de vie
indispensable pour traîner ses 50 kg de
pommes de terre tout à coup une grosse
limousine noire frêne un type en
décembre couvert de chevalière en coco
et de chaussures en or le tambazané
cravate framboise il croise la
villageoises et la toise tu suis oui
Françoise après avoir allumé un Havane
méprisant il lui souffle la fumée au
visage
merci pour la vieille ça la réchauffé
t'as pas l'air mémère lui crache-t-il au
visage
c'est réponds la dame en cherchant dans
ses cabas une montre gousset quel
cachait dans ses pommes de terre et le
car
le type éclate de rire
et repart dans sa grosse limousine
partout
la pauvre vieille
soupe comme ça quelques instants en
essayant d'attraper un dernier tubercule
qui roule sur la chaussée
et puis c'était
j'ai vomi
une ambulance est arrivé l'emporté puis
après je sais plus ce qui s'est passé
un peu enfin que le vent frais me
redonne le courage de vivre
terrifiant on va expliquer vous je suis
fort étonné de vous voir en cet état-là
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis simplement l'atterrissante
vérité mais parler à m'y parler le vieil
vieille vieille négresse
portant 200 kg de pommes de terre
pour nourrir sa niche et dans sa case
affamé qui s'aniché
j'allais lui proposer de l'aider quand
une énorme voiture noire
me coupe la route
voilà l'Asie
par dessus
feutre
s'approche la vieille qui revenait son
marché il se plante devant elle
la regarde avec son côté voilà
s'évanouisse sirène ambulance infirmier
brancard on me bouscule la pluie se
mettrait tomber c'est pas abuses les
aperçu
de quoi
il y a encore du sang sur vos chaussures
au revoir madame tronche
et puis la vie continue
c'est comme ça
pardon madame vous avez l'heure s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]